eight news now breaking news alert
we start here at six o'clock with some
exciting breaking news
a reopening date has been revealed for
the palms i know we've been waiting for
this one for longer than two years so
the website shows the resort plans to
start service once again april 27th the
palms closed during the pandemic march
2020 and then never reopened station
casinos sold the property and the san
manuel band of mission indians they
bought it for 650 million bucks last may
it is the first native american owned
resort and casino in las vegas they're
keeping some things tossing out some
other things so we'll all get to see it
april 27th which restaurants may still
be there which may be new restaurants or
whatever like bobby flays that was a big
one don't know if that's sticking around
but mabel's is the barbecue joint people
love that right i saw the article on
that just recently so a lot of faves
there and a lot what the ghost bar
that's
they
know
hot spot
wow okay well congratulations palms nice
to have a date and i know a lot of
locals are going to be happy
we'll all be there are we happy with the
weather